[Musik]
das ist ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie lebt in deutschland wohnt sie hier
in der stadt
aber wo ist das kennt ihr jahres
fahrradladen sowas möchte sie trinken
was gibt s ja wir haben abgesagt was wir
beim cola und limonade
also ich nehme mein bier werden auch
kaffee und themenangebot danke für mich
bitte einen kaffee wenn wir schon zucker
ja mit viel milch aber wenig zucker aber
ich mache das was ist mit dir nico ist
auch tust was möchtest du trinken cola
bitte also freundlich hat eine idee wie
wir post das foto von jahre bei buck und
fragen wer kennt diese fahrradladen und
so finden wir die adresse raus
habt ihr hunger ja hier sind die
speisekarte
also dann groß großen da habe ich hier